Good Morning #Beleive nation
Today message is...
Put in the EFFORT
Over to you by Ray Lewis
beat me to the ball every play that
ain't gonna do a talent that's just got
everything to do it effort nothing else
15 straight years 12 Pro Bowls later if
you want numbers I don't saw all of it
and the only thing that's kept me around
it's my effort so you put on this all I
ever knew because I want a number on
recruit I want a number one line back I
won't even in the media guy all I ever
knew what's effort will get me seen on
the tape effort will get me notice to
get to the lead effort but one day take
care my mom and my kids ever which is
between you and you nobody else can give
you a fleet health efforts with Inside
Man so anything well I think that
putting the effort and anything is
really important and definitely more
important than getting fixated on what
other people think about you even if you
haven't put that four so far I got good
examples up actually myself when I first
came to this country out
no English and people really picked on
me okay chica Moran all right yeah
people clicked on me on the way I spoke
and and instead of getting the scurried
about what they say and just just kind
of going to my own corner I started
watching a lot of movies i started
getting outside of my personal bubble
and speaking to people no matter how
silly i sounded and and that right now
my english is much better than it was
before i'm not saying i'm a motivational
speaker or anything but uh i would say i
would prove more than i would have
thought or if I haven't put over when my
mom came from Italy she didn't know any
English and she watched movies too as a
way to learn English and now I we get a
lot of comments below from people saying
that they learn English by watching
these videos that's like a full circle
moment it's really cool i love this
message i think if you look at my own
experience i've never been the most
talented at whatever I was doing it was
just by putting in the effort and being
consistent one of the comments that i
always get about my youtube channel is
the consistency right we're putting up
mostly three videos a day every single
day not always on the weekends but
almost every single day we'll responding
to every single comment on the channel
and it's it's just a lot of work it's a
lot of grinding it's a lot of effort
right i socked when I first got on
camera where you can go back to my
channel look at the first videos I was
really really bad i took i see how the
people who are starting now and look at
their first videos and i look at where
they are for like 20 videos and there's
so much further ahead then I was after
videos and they look at their progress
you know like I'm so so bad i'm still
not I'm not good enough and and they
want to quit and give up and it blows my
mind because I was just so much worse
than they were and the thing that got me
through was just another video another
video in another video and we put almost
3000 videos up on the channel that all
the more public that's three thousand
videos worth of practice that most
people can't keep up with and so
whatever it is that you want to get
better at you know expect to suck at the
start is something new it's something
that you're trying for the first time so
you are going to suck at it and the way
to get better is to just keep practicing
and practicing and practicing every day
get a little bit better a little bit
better a little better but putting the
effort can overcome any mountain
regardless of how skilled and talented
you are the answer is hard work so the
question today today is how could you do
something different to motivate yourself
on putting the effort what are you going
to do differently to motivate yourself
to put in the effort leave in the
comments below will join the discussion
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shut up and spread
go